now the big news on this friday mass
guidance in the valley is changing and
some hotels on the strip are leading the
way good afternoon thank you for joining
us at four i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm christian caceres well this all
comes from new recommendations from the
health district
bottom line wear a mask indoors in
public regardless of vaccinations
joe muller joins us live from the
venetian to explain joe good afternoon
good afternoon the venetian and the
westgate are now having their employees
wear masks regardless if they're
vaccinated or not as for everybody else
the health district is now recommending
you wear a mask if you head indoors to
places like casinos here on the strip
now this morning the health district
explained regardless if you are
vaccinated or not
you should wear that mask indoors to
decrease the risk of spread
it is suggested to put on in stores
malls casinos and other crowded areas a
majority of the recent cases are people
who are not vaccinated
people visiting las vegas say they
aren't thrilled about these
recommendations but don't mind doing it
and if we're vaccinated aren't we the
ones that don't need to wear the mouse
i don't know it's it's very confusing
i'm still gonna wear my mask
not outside um like right now humidity
i won't wear it i'll try to social
distance as much as i can but on the
insides i definitely will
64 percent of the adult population has
at least one of their shots here in
southern nevada majority of the cases
are
younger people between the ages of 18
and 45.
today the health district said despite
the increase in cases hospitals are
still doing okay at this point
now back out here live they also
explained a majority of these new cases
here in southern nevada are people that
are
not vaccinated and just a short time ago
the southern nevada health district
did contact me and say they are working
to set up more testing sites around the
valley reporting live here on the strip
joe mohler eight news now